[Musique]
c'est un art de vivre autant qu'un
savoir-faire le repas à la française
classée depuis 2010 au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO
un moment de partage que l'on vit aussi
entre frères d'armes
convivialité et cohésion avec une
nourriture de qualité on alimente le
physique mais aussi le moral du
combattant
un défi permanent pour les plus de 3000
cuisiniers des armées
outre à tout de l’armée française la
ration de combat
jalousie des autres nations elle est un
bout de terroir qui accompagne les
militaires durant leurs opérations
jusque dans les endroits les plus
reculés de la planète
c'est clair ça on peut commencer et ben
c'est parti Go
il est 7h30 à l'école des fourriers de
Querqueville à deux pas de Cherbourg une
quinzaine d'élèves s'affaire déjà en
cuisine
tout juste engagé dans l'armée pour
certains en reconversion militaire pour
d'autres il débute en cuisine c'est le
mouvement
ment avec de la farine et on continue
comme ça on peut aussi un peu malaxer
ils ont 4 heures pour préparer un repas
de l'entrée au dessert pour deux
personnes sous l'oeil expert du premier
maître Amélie
cette passionné de cuisine a longtemps
exercer son métier en mer avant de
revenir transmettre son savoir sur la
terre ferme
la seule fois ça suffit c'est futur
cuisiniers doivent apprendre à gérer
leur stress et appliquer les conseils
prodigués
[Musique]
faites attention pour prendre une
spatule en plastique parce que vous
voyez à chaque fois que vous mettez un
coup de statue en fer vous arrivez à
découper
[Musique]
ok maintenant il faut que j'enlève le
cercle pour faire finition de la dorure
ici
[Musique]
je ne veux pas engager depuis 5 mois
Françoise ne s'imaginait pas forcément
cuisinier militaire
j'ai mis les carcasses j'ai rincé mon
poulet après j'ai remis au feu avec de
l'eau froide et parfois et du coup j'ai
mis tout ce qui est légumes carottes
oignons céleri poireaux et du coup je
laisse venir en évolution
aujourd'hui elle est l'une des élèves
les plus appliquées de la promotion
chaque année ils sont 600 stagiaires à
suivre une formation à l'école des
fourriers de Querqueville une des deux
écoles rattachées au commissariat des
armées entre cours théoriques et mise en
pratique les élèves acquièrent un bagage
solide geste technique respect des
règles d'hygiène vocabulaire culinaires
tout doit être maîtrisé
au début j'avais un peu peur je savais
pas dans quoi je me lançais
après suite à ça on découvre le métier
en voyant surtout les instructeurs tout
se passe très bien
à quelques minutes du service les élèves
s'appliquent à dresser leurs assiettes
numéro 15 très joli on part
14 un petit poilu un peu un poil de
cuisson 14 en salle les premiers clients
arrivent tous travaillent à l'école et
se glisse pour quelques instants
seulement comme dans la peau d'un jury
Top chef
du coup là on commence
à faire même avant de commencer à manger
on vérifie un peu tous les ingrédients
si c'est conforme à ce qui a été
présenté et également la température de
l'assiette pour voir si c'est bien dans
la dans la conformité de ce qui a été
présenté il a répondu une fois le repas
terminé la pression redescend enfin pour
ses cuisiniers en formation
on est vraiment là pour leur apprendre à
coeur de métier parce qu'ils sont sans
diplôme ces jeunes et là ils vont sortir
de cette formation avec un diplôme un
cap ce qui n'est pas négligeable à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui donc l'armée a
vraiment coeur à donner des diplômes aux
jeunes et c'est une formation qui font
ou là en plus on est colle ils sont
rémunérés donc c'est vraiment une chose
pour eux cuire les œufs dans l'eau
bouillante 10 à 12 minutes pour faire
des œufs durs cette formation connait
une belle réussite
98% des élèves décrochent leur CAP un
diplôme reconnu dans le civil et qui les
forme aux exigences de la cuisine des
armées
les contraintes militaires sont des
contraintes bien spécifiques par rapport
à la restauration collective civile
l'amplitude horaire les certains
matériels malgré tout l'obligation du
métier militaire l'entraînement physique
l'entraînement outir l'entraînement
opérationnel les formations internes
nous resterons travaillent pour la
grande majorité 7 jours sur 7 365 jours
par an donc des contraintes bien
spécifiques que l'on peut difficilement
exporter sur une formation externe les
élèves vont maintenant retourner dans
leurs unités pour mettre en pratique
leur nouveau savoir-faire
à quelques mètres de là d'autres chefs
s'affairent plus expérimentés c'est
cuisiniers militaires vont prochainement
être déployés au Sahel au sein de
l'opération barkhane
pour s'y préparer ils doivent revoir
tous les rudiments de la cuisine en
milieu opérationnel durant 15 jours ils
vont s'entraîner en conditions réelles
sur des cuisines de campagne qu'il
retrouveront sur le terrain
plusieurs fois envoyés au Mali le
caporal-chef romain aime partager ses
astuces de cuisine avec ses collègues
à 63 degrés exactement
afin qu'on n'ait pas de risque
de bactéries
encadré par la judence Stéphane ils ont
4 heures pour réaliser un menu complet
pour 90 personnes des coupes de viande
oignons émincés et pommes épluchées les
gestes sont précis et rapides
soudain le formateur décide de pimenter
un peu les choses donc là je vais aller
on va dire que quand est attaqué je vais
aller déclencher l'alerte en donnant
deux coups de klaxon et là ils doivent
aller se mettre en place sur les postes
de combat et ensuite assurer la sécurité
alimentaire de tous les aliments qui
sont sortis
immédiatement les cuisiniers troc le
tablier contre les armes chacun se
positionne à son poste de combat
cuisinier mais avant tout soldats
[Musique]
c'est qui va en Belgique
permet à ces militaires bientôt projetés
de revoir les fondamentaux
[Musique]
tout ce qui est pas utilisé au frais
donc
gaspillage voilà
l'alerte terminée l'adjudant rassemble
ses personnels pour un débriefing
vous avez laissé le rondeau sur les
plaques sachant que c'est de la fonte ça
chauffe s'il y a quelque chose dedans ça
reste au chaud longtemps ça chauffe et
ça peut prendre feu donc ça faut pas
oublier on retient le Rondo mais sur les
plaques on produit
tous se remettent derrière les fourneaux
pas question de retarder le premier
service
c'est fondamental d'avoir un bon soutien
c'est le comme je le disais que ça soit
dans le matériel dans l'habillement dans
la cuisine si on n'a pas de soutien
forcément le soldat il part pas au
combat quoi il part pas au combat d'un
soldat qui part en combat avec le ventre
vide entre guillemets ou ici la mal
mangé il va pas assurer la même mission
que si il était le ventre bien rempli
quoi tout simplement
le déjeuner à peine servi les premiers
compliments arrivent en cuisine faire à
manger ses biens mais faire plaisir
c'est encore mieux et parfois même cela
relève du tour de force
à Brest nous montons à bord de
l’endromède
ce chasseur de mines de la Marine
nationale peut accueillir jusqu'à 50
personnes
[Musique]
mise en service en 1984 il abrite une
cuisine extrêmement petite dans laquelle
travaille le maître Cédric 17 ans de
service et son adjoint le quartier
maître Ulrich un ancien cuisinier civil
en plus de leur casquette de cuisinier
les deux militaires ont comme le reste
de l'équipage plusieurs tâches à bord ce
matin
Ulrich est appelée au poste de manœuvre
pour le départ du bateau
il doit relever les défenses sortent de
bouée noire qui empêche le navire de
heurter le quai
[Musique]
de retour en cuisine les deux hommes se
lancent dans la préparation du repas
avec la houle les cuisiniers doivent
redoubler de vigilance pour ne pas
risquer de se blesser
et le truc c'est que bah on essaye de
faire en sorte
que chacun puisse se retrouver à un
endroit différent dans la cuisine c'est
à dire que si par exemple moi je vais me
mettre sur l'entrée je vais me
positionner sur un endroit de la cuisine
et mon chef s'il veut travailler sur le
plat va se positionner sur une autre
partie de la cuisine en sachant que
chaque produit chaque
élément qu'on va faire donc on va
assembler on essaie de faire des
rotations au niveau du plan de travail
et tout pour jamais justement soit se
mélanger soit encombrer sous le marché
dessus on essaie vraiment de trouver
cette osmose entre tous les deux
moi la maison ma cuisine elle fait cette
taille là mais on est que 4 la faut
faire à manger pour 50 moi ça on
s'habitue on fait attention parce que ça
peut être dangereux aussi
l'eau bouillante les couteaux
faut que tout soit arrivé dans la
cuisine parce que ça peut être vite
dangereux
le premier service débute à 11h il ne
faut pas traîner
à table les marins sont répartis dans
trois espaces différents
premiers carrés réservé à l'équipage
le carré commandant ou se retrouve les
officiers supérieurs et subalternes
et enfin le carré officier mariné
synonyme de détente lors du repas est
tout particulièrement apprécié
travailler sur un bateau c'est vivre sur
un bateau 24 heures sur 24 et dans ce
univers les seuls moments devraient
détendre où il y a une vraie coupure
c'est le moment des repas c'est le seul
moment où vous n'êtes pas accaparé par
votre travail
sur la demi-heure ou les 40 minutes que
le marin va passer au carré pour se
détendre il va passer 75% de son temps
devant une assiette et comme pour
n'importe qui
si vous allez au restaurant entre amis
vous avez beau être entre amis avec les
meilleurs amis que vous ayez si vous
allez dans un mauvais restaurant et bien
ça va gâcher votre plaisir pour un marin
c'est un peu la même chose d'accord et
très content de se retrouver au carré
avec ses camarades de pouvoir détendre
mais si dans son assiette il y a quelque
chose qui lui plaît pas ou qui est mal
cuisiné ou mal préparé et bien ça va
nuire à son moral et il faut absolument
pas sous-estimer ce moment là
en débit des contraintes du métier les
cuisiniers apprécient leur mode de vie
[Musique]
aussi je pense que c'est une réussite
parce que souvent quand on est bien nous
voir en cuisine en disant que c'était
très bon mais tout s'est bien passé
c'est gratifiant
on le sait moins mais les bâtiments sont
de véritables ambassadeurs de la
gastronomie française
le savoir-faire des cuisiniers de la
marine il est aussi une façon de
valoriser la France à l'extérieur donc
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs de repas
officiel qui arrive généralement le
premier jour de l'Escale on reçoit des
autorités qui peuvent être parfois très
hautes autorités des ministres des
ambassadeurs voire des chefs d'État
avoir des bateaux et là on se retrouve à
voir tout le savoir-faire de nos
cuisiniers pour sortir des choses
absolument incroyables
la nourriture un repère pour tous dans
les armées qui nécessitent une
organisation colossale
cependant la Grande Guerre que la France
va en prendre conscience entre 1914 et
1918 ils sont nombreux à être mobilisés
près de 8 millions dans les armées
françaises sur l'ensemble du conflit
déployés sur un front de plus de 700 km
autant de bouche qu'il va falloir
nourrir dans les zones de combat les
services d'intendance mettent alors en
place une logistique gigantesque
avec un défi de taille acheminez la
nourriture jusque dans les tranchées
les moyens mis en oeuvre sont
rudimentaires mais ingénieux
les cuisines mobiles appelées roulantes
mais aussi les boulangeries et les
boucheries de campagne se déplacent
jusque sur les lignes de front pour
alimenter les troupes
une organisation qui perdure au début de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale
un kilo de bois par 3 kg de pain cuit et
cette boulangerie produit 150000 kg de
pain chaque jour
du soldat du pain et du vin tels que
légumes et surtout du bœuf assaisonné en
conserve appelé singe dans l'argot des
soldats
[Musique]
les années 1990 marque une étape clé
pendant la guerre du Golfe plus de 15000
militaires sont mobilisés plusieurs
milliers de tonnes de matériel et de
vivre sont affrétés
de réétudier la variété l'équilibre et
la durabilité de la nourriture proposée
l'usage de la ration de combat
introduites en 1946 se généralise
aujourd'hui on parle de la ration de
combat individuel et réchauffables c'est
une boîte en carton sur mesure et légère
à l'intérieur trois repas qui couvrent
les besoins nutritionnels journaliers du
militaire et un kit de réchauffage
la ration doit se conserver longtemps et
résister aux conditions les plus
extrêmes
les menus sont variés l'objectif pouvoir
tenir plus de deux semaines sans jamais
manger le même repas pour éviter la
monotonie de nouvelles recettes sont
régulièrement proposées tartiflette et
kebab rillettes fromage fondu et crème
dessert sont désormais au menu
pour tout connaître de la ration du
soldat il faut prendre la direction de
l'établissement logistique du
commissariat des armées à Angers où les
produits sont reçus et assemblés
[Musique]
tout commence par le contrôle de chaque
lot dessa réception des échantillons
sont prélevés et subissent une large
batterie de tests au sein du laboratoire
du commissariat des armées
nous sommes un laboratoire accrédité
crédité ça signifie que en fait on ne
peut pas nous opposer un résultat
d'analyse si un fournisseur
ne correspond pas aussi bien lors d'une
analyse chimique ou microbiologique il
aura beaucoup de mal à faire appel sur
les essais que nous avons formulés ainsi
que les analyses justement de par cet
accréditation chaque année ce
laboratoire effectue pas moins de 80 000
analyses
le Département de microbiologie est en
charge du contrôle sanitaire des denrées
alimentaires qui rentrent dans la ration
de combat donc ce contrôle est réalisé à
partir de la qualité des charges donc
très très complet et donc il permet de
rechercher les micro-organismes qui
peuvent avoir un impact sur la santé du
combattant et ainsi garantir sa sécurité
alimentaire
tout à l'heure donc j'analyser un potage
en fait donc c'est un produit qui rentre
dans la relation de combat on recherche
en fait tous les organismes qu'ils ont
prévu donc par le cahier de charge on
est le cas de basilic Sirius donc c'est
un germe qui provoque des diarrhées et
des vomissements et en fait si le
combattant ingère cette bactérie qui
produit une toxine il peut avoir de
graves symptômes sur le terrain et donc
on préfère éviter cette situation le
laboratoire vérifie aussi que les
produits apportent tout ce qui est
nécessaire aux militaire
le rôle du Département de chimie du
labocca et de contrôler la qualité des
constituants des rations alimentaires la
qualité concerne différents domaines on
vérifie la qualité organoleptique le
produit doit être bon la qualité
nutritionnelle
idiot contenir l'industriement qui sont
nécessaires et qui sont définis dans la
cahier des charges et on contrôle aussi
certains critères sanitaires qui
concernent la sécurité alimentaire du
consommateur
concernant la qualité de nutritionnelle
on détermine également les minéraux les
glucides et les protéines et enfin la
valeur énergétique pour vérifier que le
produit apporte suffisamment d'énergie
aux consommateurs
à noter que le goût et la qualité des
matières premières comptent pour 70%
dans les critères de sélection loin
devant le coût du produit
une fois les tests passés les produits
sont assemblés grâce à une chaîne
entièrement robotisée
en fait c'est très simple c'est comme un
corps humain vous avez une tête une
colonne vertébrale et des membres la
tête ce sont les ordinateurs chaque
robot est conduit par un ordinateur
[Musique]
sur le tapis les robots saisissent et
positionne les produits à leur place
dans les boîtes
entrée plat dessert et kit de
réchauffage barres chocolatées pâtes de
fruits ou encore mouchoirs
[Applaudissements]
la cadence est impressionnante en
moyenne plus de 10 000 rations de ce
type sont produites quotidiennement
c'est un million 800 000 environ par an
chaque ration est numérotée pour
garantir la traçabilité
en fin de chaîne les palettes sont
étiquetées et stockées avant d'être
distribués à l'ensemble des armées en
métropole à l'Outre-mer comme à
l'étranger
nous nous avons une obligation sur les
locataires de stocker 300 000 rations
les autres établissements de Brétigny et
de Marseille concours eux pour 250 000
rations chacun donc ce qui fait qu'une
réserve sur la métropole elle est de
800.000 rations
ce système permet de répondre rapidement
à un besoin y compris parfois pour aider
les populations civiles en 2017 après
l'ouragan Irma 100.000 rations sont
envoyés en urgence sur l'île de
Saint-Martin
[Musique]
pour ces rations l'armée mise avant tout
sur des produits made in France pour
cela elle s'est entourée d'une
cinquantaine de partenaires industriels
locaux une partie des plats sont
cuisinées en Vendée aux Sables-d'Olonne
chez titok une entreprise familiale
fondée par un couple de passionnés
Christophe et Nathalie landais il
fournissent les armées depuis près de 20
ans maintenant
leur spécialité la fabrication de
produits déshydratés et lyophilisées
historiquement on réalisait des
préparations culinaires déshydratées
type bouillon fond de sauce et puis basé
au sable d'Olonne on a découvert
l'alimentation lyophilisée grâce au
skipper du Vendée Globe qui nous ont
apporté leurs informations quant à leurs
attentes nutritionnelles et gustatives
de ce type de produit les skippers leur
première
attente c'est le poids et bien sûr les
attentes de des militaires sont
absolument les mêmes puisqu'il faut dans
le sac embarquer un maximum d'énergie
avec un minimum de poids on a la recette
magique et mathématiques
propose une cinquantaine de plats au
total dont une dizaine pour les
différentes rations des armées de
l'entrée au dessert en passant par le
plat principal les grands classiques de
la cuisine française sont revisités à la
sauce lyophilisée si j'ai un produit qui
s'appelle un plat lieu philisé la
recette c'est du riz bœuf façon goulash
c'est une des recettes qui a été choisie
par l'armée française pour être dans les
rations notamment la ration commando une
ration très technique aromate et pis
poivrons bœuf fluophilisé riz on vient
ajouter de l'eau dans le produit et le
consommateur le militaire en
l'occurrence consomme directement le
produit dans le sachet
un procédé utile lorsque les
entraînements et les missions imposent
une autonomie et que le poids est une
contrainte
l'opération est quasi instantanée 5
minutes suffisent
ateur ça permet d'enlever l'eau d'un
produit surgelé en fait on a une grosse
peur parce qu'on met sous vide donc on
diminue la pression et la température et
ça nous permet l'eau qui est sous forme
de glace dans notre produit de passer
directement sous forme de vapeur donc il
y a plutôt dans le produit et le produit
garde ses propriétés aussi bien
nutritionnelles que physique il sort
exactement du même aspect que le produit
surgelé et ça se réhydra très facilement
nous n'aurons pas plus de détails sur ce
procédé bien particulier
on va dire que c'est un peu le secret
défense aussi de l'entreprise que de
pouvoir réaliser des produits sur mesure
avec des contraintes très fortes en
termes
sanitaire bien sûr en termes
d'apport énergétique en terme
déséquilibre de la recette
la lyophilisation permet de garder les
apports nutritionnels et organoleptiques
de l'aliment autrement dit son apparence
son odeur ou sa texture et surtout son
goût
pour Christophe landais cuisinier de
formation ses capitales tout comme la
provenance des produits
naturels dans notre manière de penser
aujourd'hui de d'avoir une éthique et de
s'approcher d'une production de plus en
plus locale si possible en tout cas
franco-française et on a des exemples
assez fréquents de militaires qui sont
très heureux de voir sur nos packaging
Les Sables-d'Olonne on leur amène un
rayon de soleil dans leur assiette la
ration de combat comme un condensé du
savoir-faire culinaire français
parce qu'elle apporte énergie et confort
dans un quotidien difficile les armées
prennent soin de l'alimentation de leur
personnel en accord avec les objectifs
de la loi de programmation militaire
nourrir le combattant c'est aussi en
quelque sorte le nerf de la guerre
[Musique]